le paracétamol et l'aspirine ces
antidouleurs sont aujourd'hui pointés du
doigt en raison du risque de surdosage
dans les années 70 il était déjà
facilement accessible en pharmacie est
parfois mal utilisé un constat qui
inquiète est alors certains spécialistes
l'aspirine à susceptible si elle n'est
pas prescrite dans de bonnes conditions
et sous surveillance de provoquer toute
une série troubles qui vendent
l'hémorragie digestive l'urticaire dans
les années 90 la consommation d'aspirine
et de paracétamol fait toujours partie
des reflex avec un risque celui du
surdosage
ce médecin lance l alerte en 1998
si vous prenez plus de 3 g de
paracétamol par jour c'est votre foi qui
peut tomber en panne
des mises en garde qui ne suffiront pas
à changer les habitudes des français
l'usagé du paracétamol a même augmenté
de 53 % ces dix dernières années
un geste banal pour beaucoup quand j'ai
mal je prends du paracétamol mais
modérément ses douleurs persistent ou
j'en prends un peu plus pour moi c'est
pas dangereux d'en prendre en 2007
malgré les risques l'automédication et
est même encouragé par les pouvoirs
publics
une idée pour réduire le déficit de la
sécurité sociale le rapport ministériel
encourage ainsi la vente de l'aspirine
et du paracétamol en libre service
l'initiative était alors dénoncé par
certains professionnels de santé
ce pharmacien alertait encore une fois
sur la dangerosité potentielle de ces
antidouleurs
si aujourd'hui on doit augmenter la
consommation des médicaments et
augmenter le nombre de boîtes on aura
que des inconvénients de santé publique
au travers de huit ans plus tard en 2015
en plus du risque hépatique une étude
britannique révèle ait d'autres effets
indésirables liés à la surconsommation
de paracétamol
le paracétamol augmenterait le risque de
maladies cardiovasculaires
d'insuffisance rénale et de troubles
gastro intestinaux comme les ulcères en
plus de son action sur le foie et sur le
système hormonal en 2018 la mort d'une
jeune femme par intoxication au
paracétamol relançait le débat
un an plus tard l' agence du médicament
dévoilait une campagne de prévention
aujourd'hui le paracétamol et l'aspirine
font toujours partie des substances
actives les plus vendus en france
[Musique]